Die messdaten des australischen radioteleskops experimente
global adview
ionisation ages sind wirklich mehr als mysteriös
denn sie widersprechen einfach voll und ganz dem bild das wir von unserem universum haben doch ein
internationales forschungsteam hat jetzt eine äußerst spannende hypothese aufgestellt mit der diese messdaten
eigentlich ganz prima erklärt werden können dabei berufen sie sich auf dunkle photonen also dunkle lichtteilchen
bisschen paradox das ganze könnte wenn nicht sogar das standardmodell der teilchenphysik
erweitern alle wichtigen infos zu der ganzen sache kommt er jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Alles im universum ist irgendwie dunkel fangen wir an mit der sogenannten
dunklen materie rund 80 prozent der materie im universum
besteht wohl daraus ein stoff den noch nie jemand gesehen hat ja es halt dunkel mit verschiedenen methoden versuchen
forschungsteams weltweit herauszufinden was hinter der dunklen materie stecken direkt kann man sie sehen und zwar durch ihre
auswirkungen auf die schwerkraft schätzung zufolge macht sie wohl knapp 27 prozent der
energiedichte des weltalls auf die
sogenannte marianische materie dagegen was der alles uns bekannte besteht macht dagegen nur fünf prozent aus kurz gesagt
die dunkle materie ist so etwas wie der heilige gral der physik dazu kommt dem universum wohl auch noch die
geheimnisvolle dunkle energie schon wieder dunkel über die wir ja auch schon öfter berichtet haben forschungsteams weltweit
verstehen sie auch noch nicht wirklich doch sie agiert wohl wie eine art anti schwerkraft die das universum auseinandertreibt
zudem wird sie wohl umso größer je mehr sich der raum ausdehnen
das war es aber noch nicht flüssig aktiven vermuten dem universum neben der dunklen materie und der dunklen
die auch noch so genannte dunkle
photonen also
dunkle lichtteilchen ein wenig paradox dunkles licht im gegensatz zu den konventionellen
photonen also den leuchtenden lichtteilchen haben sie in der vorstellung der fachleute eine masse und während ihnen direkt
nachweisbar und zwar durch ihren zerfall in
elektronen und positronen
also den antiteilchen der elektronen
auch die dunklen photonen sollen nach ansicht mancher forschungsteams eine kraft tragen eine uns bislang völlig unbekannte naturkraft
ihre existenz wurde darauf schließen lassen dass ein
verborgener sektor existiert der unter anderem auch teilchen der dunklen materie enthalten könnte in diesem zusammenhang haben jetzt
messdaten des australischen radioteleskop
experiment zur detektion obel epoche
ionisation ages für eine riesige überraschung gesorgt das
internationale forschungsteam hatte eigentlich das ziel neue modelle zur dunkle materie zu testen dabei griffen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler auf die sogenannte
21 zentimeter kosmologie zurück denn hiermit kann man erkenntnisse zur frühzeit des universums
gewinnen und das ist der kosmische hintergrund 200 millionen jahre nach dem urknall
haben sich wohl die ersten sterne gebildet und für neues licht im universum gesorgt doch die damals beteiligten
himmelskörper die sind heutzutage mit teleskopen nicht mehr direkt zu beobachten doch das riecht damals hat wohl mit wasserstoff reagiert
und somit eine
charakteristische struktur im spektrum der kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung
hinterlassen und diese ist auch heute noch zu beobachten und zwar bei einer wellenlänge von
21 zentimetern daher auch der name
21 zentimeter kosmologie dazu einer der beteiligten forscher aus österreich josef radler die
21 zentimeter kostenlos die hat das potenzial um neue modelle der dunkle materie zu testen doch die
messdaten des teleskops zeigen dass das 21 cm signal deutlich vom erwarteten wert
abweicht daraus schließt das forschungsteam das höchstwahrscheinlich eine wechselwirkung mit dunkler materie
stattgefunden haben muss eine erklärung für den nun gemessenen effekt könnte sein dass in der frühzeit des universums
mehr lichtteilchen am start gewesen sein könnten als man bislang
angenommen hatte konkret gehen die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler davon aus dass sich dunkle photonen in
herkömmliche lichtteilchen verwandelt haben genau das könnte dann die unerwartete stärke des
gemessenen signals erklären diese hypothese des forschungsteams basiert auf der vermutung dass sich dunkle
photonen unter bestimmten umständen in normale photonen umfallen könnten dazu bradler
unsere theorie beruht auf der annahme und dunkler photon die nur eine minimale erweiterung des standardmodells
darstellen jedenfalls ist eines klar die entdeckung dunkler photonen wäre eine wahre sensation und
vergleichbar mit der entdeckung der monde um den planeten jupiter durch galileo die einmal ein
theoretischer physiker aus princeton betont hatte wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann abonniert am besten auch kriegs um
science-fiction auf englisch da gibt es nämlich manchmal themen auch zuerst dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die glocke vergessen und dann runter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
geheimnisvolles teilchen entdeckt mysteriöse vorgänge in der antarktis bis dann
bleibt dran